i would guess that you're reasonably
familiar with linear scales these are
the scales that you would typically see
in most of your math classes and so just
to make sure we know we're talking about
and maybe thinking about in a slightly
different way let me draw a linear
number line let me start with zero and
what we're going to do is we're going to
say look if i move this distance right
over here and if i move that distance to
the right that's equivalent to adding
10. so if you start at 0 and you add 10
that would obviously get you to 10. if
you move that distance to the right
again you're going to add 10 again that
would get you 2 that would get you to
20. and obviously we could keep doing it
and get to 30 40 50 so on and so forth
and also just looking at what we did
here if we go the other direction if we
start here and move that same distance
to the left we're clearly subtracting
10. 10
minus 10 is equal to zero so if we move
that distance to the left again we would
get to negative 10 and if we did it
again we would get to negative 20. so
the general idea is however many times
we move that distance we are essentially
adding or however many times we move
that distance to the right we're
essentially adding that multiple of 10.
if we move do it twice we're adding 2
times 10. and that not only works for
whole numbers it would work for
fractions as well where would 5 be well
to get to 5 we only have to multiply 10
or i guess one way to think about is 10
the way to think about is 5 is half of
10. and so if we want to only go half of
10 we only have to go half this distance
so if we go if we go half this distance
if we go half this distance that will
get us to one half times 10. in this
case that would be 5. if we go to the
left that would get us 2 negative 5. and
there's nothing let me draw that a
little bit more centered negative 5. and
there's nothing really new here we're
just kind of thinking about it in a
slightly novel way it's going to be
useful when we start thinking about
logarithmic but this is just the number
line that you've always known if we want
to put 1 here we would move 1 10 of the
distance because one is one tenth of ten
so this would be one two three four i
could just put i could i could label
frankly any any number right over here
now this was a situation where we add 10
or subtract 10 but it's completely
legitimate to have an alternate way of
thinking what of what you do when you
move this distance and let's think about
that
so let's say i have another line over
here and you might guess this is going
to be the logarithmic number line let me
give a
give ourselves some space and let's
start this logarithmic number line at
one and i'll let you think about after
this video why i didn't start it at zero
and if you start at one and instead of
moving that so i'm still going to define
that same distance that same distance is
a little bit smaller i'm still going to
define that same distance but instead of
saying that that same distance is adding
10 when i move to the right i'm going to
say when i move the right that distance
on this new number line that i've
created that is the same thing as
multiplying by 10. and so if i move that
distance i start at 1 i multiply by 10
that gets me 2 that gets me to 10. and
then if i multiply by 10 again if i
multiply by 10 again if i move by that
distance again i'm multiplying by 10
again and so that would get me to 100. i
think you can already see the difference
that's happening and what about moving
to the left that distance
well we already have kind of said what
happens because if we start here if we
start at 100 and move to the left of
that distance what happens well i
divided by 10 i divided by 10 100
divided by 10 gets me 10. 10 divided by
10 gives me 1. and so if i move that
distance
if i move that distance to the left
again i'll divide by 10 again that would
get me 2
that would get me to 1 10. and if i move
that distance to the left again that
would get me to that would get me to 1
1 over 100 and so the general idea is is
however many times i move that distance
to the right i'm multiplying 10 i'm
multiplying my starting point by 10 that
many times and so for example
for example when i moved that distance
twice so this whole distance right over
here i went that distance twice so this
is times 10 times 10 which is the same
thing as times 10
to the second power
and so really i'm raising 10 to what i'm
multiplying it times 10 to whatever
power however many times i'm jumping to
the right same thing if i go to the left
if i go to the left that distance twice
if i go to the left let me do that in a
new color
if i go to the left that distance twice
this will be the same thing as dividing
by 10 twice dividing by 10 dividing by
10 which is the same thing as
multiplying by
one way to think of it 1 over 10 squared
or dividing by 10 squared is another way
of thinking about it and so that might
make a little you know that might be
hopefully a little bit intuitive and you
can already see why this is valuable we
can already on this number line plot a
much broader spectrum of things than we
can on this number line we can go all
the way up to 100 and then we even get
some nice granularity if we go down to
one-tenth and hundred one hundredth here
we get we don't get the granularity at
small scales and we also don't get to go
to really large numbers and if we go a
little distance before we get to a
thousand and then we get to ten thousand
so on and so forth so we can really
cover a much broader spectrum on this on
this line right over here but what's
also neat about this is that when you
move a fixed distance so when you move a
fixed distance on this linear number
line you're adding or subtracting that
amount so if you move that fixed
distance you're adding 2 to the right if
you go to the left you're subtracting 2.
when you do the same thing on a
logarithmic number line this is true of
any logarithmic number line you will be
scaling by a fixed factor and one way to
think about what that fixed factor is
is this idea of exponents so if you
wanted to say where would where would 2
sit on this number line
then you would just think to yourself
well
if i ask myself where does 100 sit on
that number line actually that might be
a better place to start if i said if i
didn't already apply i said where does
hundreds on that number line i would say
how many times do i have to multiply 10
by itself to get a 100 and that's how
many times i need to move this distance
and so essentially i'll be asking 10 to
the what power is equal to 100 and then
i would get that question mark is equal
to 2 and then i would move that many
spaces to plot my hundred or another way
of of stating this exact same thing is
log base 10 of 100 is equal to question
mark and this question mark is clearly
equal to 2 and that says i need to plot
the 100 to 2 of this distance to the
right and to figure out where i plot the
2 i would do the exact same thing i
would say 10 to what power
i would say 10
to what power is equal to 2 or log
base 10 of 2 is equal to what and we can
get the trusty calculator out and we can
just say
log and on most calculators if just a
log without the base specified they're
assuming base 10. so log of 2 is equal
to
roughly 0.3
0.301 so this is equal to 0.0.301
so what this tells us is we need to move
this fraction of this distance to get to
2. if we move this whole distance it's
like multiplying times 10 to the first
power but since we only want to get 10
to the 0.301 power we only want to do
0.301 of this distance so it's going to
be roughly a third of this
so let me it's going to be roughly
actually a little less than a third 0.3
not 0.33 so 2 is going to sit 2 is let
me do a little bit more to the right so
2 is going to sit right over here now
what's really cool about it is this
distance in general on this logarithmic
number line means multiplying
multiplying by two and so if you go that
same distance again you're going to get
to four
if you multiply that same distance again
you're going to multiply by 4 and you go
that same distance again you are going
you are going to get 2 8. and so if you
said well how where would i plot 5 where
would i plot 5 on this number line
well there's a couple of ways to do it
you could literally figure out what the
base 10 logarithm of 5 is and figure out
where it goes on the number line or you
could say look if i start at 10
if i start at 10
and if i move this distance to the left
i'm going to be dividing by 2. so if i
move this distance to the left i will be
dividing by 2. i know it's getting a
little bit messy here i'll maybe do
another video where we learn how to draw
a clean version of this so if i start 10
and i go that same distance i'm dividing
by 2 and so this right here would be
that right over there would be 5. now
the next question you say well how where
do i plot 3 well we could do the exact
same thing that we did with 2. we ask
ourselves
we ask ourselves what power do we have
to raise 10 to to get to 3. and to get
that we once again get our calculator
out log base 10 of 3
is equal to 0.477 so it's almost halfway
so it's almost going to be half of this
distance so half of that distance is
going to look something
like right over there so 3 is going to
go
3 is going to go right over here and you
could do the logarithm let's see we're
missing 6 7 and 8. oh we have 8 we're
missing 9. so to get 9 we just have to
multiply by 3 again so this is 3 and if
we go that same distance we multiply by
3 again 9 is going to be squeezed in
right over here 9 is going to be
squeezed in right over there and if we
want to get to 6 we just have to
multiply by 2 and we already know the
distance to multiply by 2
it's this thing right over here so you
multiply that by 2 that you do that same
distance and you're going to get you're
going to get to 6. and if you wanted to
figure out where 7 is once again you
could take the log base
you take the log
let me do it right over here so you'll
take the log of 7
is going to be 0.8 roughly 0.85 so 7 is
just going to be squeezed in squeezed in
roughly roughly right over there and so
a couple of neat things you already
appreciated one we can fit more on this
logarithmic scale and
as i did with the video that
with vi heart where she talked about how
we perceive many things with logarithmic
skills so it actually is a good way to
even understand some some of human
perception but the other really cool
thing is when we move a fixed distance
on this logarithmic scale we're
multiplying by a fixed constant now the
one kind of strange thing about this and
you might have already noticed here is
that we're we don't see the numbers
lined up the way we normally see them
there's a big jump from one to two then
a smaller jump from three to four then a
smaller jump from that from three to
four then even smaller from four to five
then even smaller five to six it gets
and then you know it's seven eight nine
you know seven is going to be right in
there they get squeeze squeeze squeezed
in tighter and tighter tighter and then
you get 10 and then you get another big
jump because once again if you want to
get to 20 you just have to multiply by
two you just have to multiply by two
again so this distance again gets us to
20. if you multi if you if you if you go
this distance over here that will get
you to 30 because you're multiplying by
three
so this right over here is of times
three distance so if you do that again
if you do that distance then that gets
you 230 you're multiplying by 3 and then
you could plot the whole same thing over
here again but hopefully this gives you
a little bit more intuition of why
logarithmic number lines look the way
they do or why logarithmic scale looks
the way it does and also it gives you a
little bit of appreciation for why it
might be useful